The Walking Dead saw some drastic changes
during its ninth season, raising countless
questions about season 10.
With the season premiere arriving soon, we've
gone ahead and pulled together everything
you need to know heading into the tenth year
of dramatic, complex, gruesome zombie madness.
For those wondering what The Walking Dead
has in store for its tenth season, an extensive
trailer was released at Comic-Con in July
2019.
One of the primary themes of the trailer was
fear — not of the undead, but rather of
the very much alive Alpha and her army of
Whisperers, both of which featured prominently
throughout season 9.
The animalistic villains appear to be a central
part of the new season and could lead to an
all-out war at some point down the road.
Before we dive into any new additions to the
cast, it's worth taking a quick trip down
memory lane to remember the primary characters
that the show lost in the catastrophically
violent course of season 9.
Rick Grimes may not be dead, but he disappeared
early on, after he successfully blew up the
bridge to stop a horde of zombies from gaining
access.
On top of that, there was the mysterious disappearance
of Maggie Rhee.
Adding to the list, we also have Jesus, who
was killed off in the fading moments of the
mid-season finale.
And finally, there's season 9's penultimate
episode, which ended with ten heads on pikes
on Alpha's creepy new border wall, including
Tara, Henry, Tammy, and Enid's.
Season 9 of The Walking Dead was highlighted
by the departure of major cast members like
Andrew Lincoln and Lauren Cohan, and it turned
out that was just the beginning.
Months before season 10's premiere, it was
already a well-established fact that Danai
Gurira, who plays the fearless Michonne, would
be leaving the show at some point during the
upcoming season.
At this point, reports seem to indicate that
Michonne will be present throughout most of
the season, which should give viewers plenty
of time to prepare for her exit.
There are only two main characters, not counting
Rick, who have made it from the dark days
of season 1 all the way to the decade mark:
Daryl and Carol.
Season 9 had a massive six-year time jump
that drastically changed the status quo for
both characters.
Post time-jump, Daryl was seen living off
on his own, while "Queen Carol" had married
King Ezekiel and adopted Henry as her son.
By the end of the season, Daryl is drawn out
of seclusion and back into the unraveling
events with the Whisperers and Carol loses
Henry, breaks up with Ezekiel, and abdicates
her crown.
The season 10 trailer seems to promise even
more changes for the long-time fan favorite
characters.
Season 9 had plenty of different plotlines
to follow, but one that stood out from the
bunch was the interesting parallel between
Carol and Alpha.
The two mothers have been to hell and back
again ever since the apocalypse hit.
Both are powerful, indomitable characters,
but they've developed dramatically different
philosophies about post-apocalyptic life.
This was already interesting to watch as their
children met and became infatuated with each
other.
On the one hand, Alpha watched as her daughter
was converted from the Whisperer ways and
ultimately taken under Carol's wing.
On the other hand, Carol faced trauma yet
again when her adopted son Henry was abducted
by Alpha and then decapitated for her gruesome
border wall.
All of these similarities and grievances set
the pair up for an epic showdown, and it appears
that season 10 is where that clash of wills
is going to take place.
Actress Melissa McBride has already declared
that she thinks there should be a confrontation,
telling the Hall H audience at San Diego Comic-Con
that:
"I feel like there deserves to be one, Carol
wants vengeance."
On top of that, showrunner Angela Kang has
also expressed excitement for the two women
to clash, adding that:
"...They’re both two incredibly powerful
women, who just happen to be on opposite sides
of this kind of epic struggle that is happening
between our people and the Whisperers.
So there’s just some really cool stuff up
ahead."
Season 10 looks to promise plenty of problems
for the heroes of The Walking Dead.
In fact, there are not one, not two, but three
primary villains already in the cards.
First off, there's Negan.
Season 9 revealed a character that was both
humbled and even a bit heroic.
Season 10 promises to continue the conflicted
character's storyline, with showrunner Kang
confirming that he'll be released from prison.
On The Talking Dead, she said:
"Negan is a guy that likes to be in the middle
of things, and being in a jail cell means
he's definitely not in the middle of things."
Negan drama aside, the show also has to deal
with the new baddie on the block: Alpha.
The horrifyingly calm leader of the Whisperers
showed her villainous chops throughout the
previous year.
On top of Alpha and her musclebound sidekick,
Beta, the new season is also set to debut
Gamma, a Whisperer who is ultra loyal to Alpha
and her agenda
Along with a host of other changes, season
9 showed that weather can play a serious role
in The Walking Dead storyline.
The season finale revealed a picturesque winter
landscape, dotted with rotting bodies and
shuffling corpses, all of which provided some
chilling new territory for the serial thriller.
The change in scenery was a fun twist to the
show's typically hot, southern setting.
And the good news is, it's not the last we'll
see of environmental challenges.
Showrunner Angela Kang told Entertainment
Weekly that:
"We're still exploring other kinds of environmental
obstacles that we haven't done and seen before,
so there will be some other new stuff to look
out for."
The promotional material has already hinted
at a couple of new natural phenomena, with
one scene showing what appears to be some
characters in front of a forest fire.
Oceanside and its waterfront location also
seem likely to factor into the new season,
opening up the doors to some aquatic adventures
— something that The Walking Dead's sister
show Fear the Walking Dead already explored
in its second season.
The massive six-year leap in season 9 had
far-reaching repercussions.
It introduced the mysterious issue of Michonne
and Daryl's scars, aged Judith Grimes into
a force to be reckoned with, surprised everyone
with her little brother, and saw a growing
divide among the communities.
With all of the shifting around, one would
think the show would settle down to a regularly
paced timeline at some point, but that's not
happening yet, and AMC isn't even trying to
make it a surprise this time.
Season 9 ended with a jump forward into the
winter.
Now, season 10 is poised to start with yet
another jump months ahead into the following
spring.
While the constant shifts are a bit jarring,
it does accelerate the age of the younger
generation.
This could serve as a perfect catalyst to
eventually tie in with the second spin-off
series, which will be set far in the future
and will follow the lives of the first generation
of humans to grow up in the post-apocalyptic
world.
As you probably recall, season 9 saw Rick
Grimes removed from the flagship Walking Dead
series, but not killed off.
Instead, the intrepid hero found himself washed
downstream along with a host of walkers, only
to be picked up by a mysterious helicopter
and flown off.
Since then, the question of what happened
to Rick has come up over and over again.
Michonne was still struggling with the loss
six years later, and Daryl seemed ready to
head off into the sunset looking for his friend
at any moment.
The hints are likely to continue coming in
season 10, as the world gears up for the planned
Rick Grimes trio of films.
This is especially likely since the hero's
storyline has even been spilling over into
the spin-off series Fear the Walking Dead,
where what looked to be the same helicopter
was spotted in one episode.
Whatever the time and place, it's certain
that the Rick Grimes saga will continue at
some point.
Whether it ever crosses back into the flagship
series or not, though, that isn't stopping
the hint-happy production team from penciling
in more clues about the hero's whereabouts.
While the situation remains steeped in mystery,
there is one meeting we can hope to see once
again.
We're talking about a reunion between Rick
and Daryl.
The two brothers in arms shared a very emotional
last few episodes together, spent tussling,
trapped in a pit, and finally making up.
"Brother, take my hand."
The connection between the two characters
is tried and true, and the possibility of
their finally finding their way back to one
another again is certainly in the cards at
this point.
In an interview at San Diego Comic-Con, former
The Walking Dead showrunner Scott Gimple was
asked if Daryl would ever see Rick again.
He responded by saying:
"…I can't rule that out.
Have you seen a little film When Harry Met
Sally?
That's how they're going to rejoin again."
In related news, there's also the juicy potential
for season 10 to feature the return of absentee
hilltop commander Maggie.
Actress Lauren Cohan's brief excursion to
her own show on ABC looks like it may end
with a quick round trip right back into the
arms of the undead.
While the failure of Cohan's new show to get
off the ground isn't necessarily enough of
a reason to assume that the fan-favorite actress
will return, there's reason to hope.
Angela Kang went right ahead and poured fuel
on the fire by making it clear that they're
doing their best to make her return a reality.
She told EW that:
"I’m not sure if I can say much about it
right now actually.
I’ll just say that we’re working on it.”
Clearly, they haven't given up on re-integrating
Maggie back into the story.
Like Rick, she was never killed off.
In fact, she was referenced multiple times
throughout season 9 and appeared to be off
on other business in an undisclosed location.
If that's not enough, promotional material
for season 10 seems to be hinting to a return
appearance.
One sneak peek shown on The Talking Dead directly
references "letters from Maggie."
"Find what you were looking for?"
"Oh, sailed down southward Oceanside's been
picking up letters from Maggie?
Wasn't anything there."
Whatever the show has in store for Cohan's
character, it hardly seems like she's going
to shuffle off this mortal coil anytime soon.
Another factor to keep in mind going into
the tenth season is the soon-to-be lack of
source material for the show to follow.
There's no doubt that the onscreen version
of The Walking Dead has already charted a
course all its own.
The comics have always served as a grounding
point from which the show could draw inspiration,
characters, and storylines.
But the truth is, the showrunners have never
shied away from altering things as they go
along.
Carl's death, Michonne and Rick's relationship,
Shane's extended lifespan, the very existence
of Daryl were all cinematic alterations that
don't have their origins in print.
That said, one question worth asking is how
things would look if there was no source material
at all.
The answer may be forthcoming sooner than
expected.
Just months before the season 10 release date,
The Walking Dead co-creator Robert Kirkman
shocked fans with a one-two punch that no
one saw coming in the comic series.
Spoilers incoming.
First, he suddenly and unexpectedly killed
off Rick Grimes.
Then, he followed it up with a final installment
and the announcement that the comic book series
was officially over.
With this sudden imposition of a hard ending
to the source material, it will be interesting
to see how AMC handles their ten-year TWD
universe plans.
We'll just have to see what that looks like
when the new season arrives on October 6th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.